spoiler warning ahead for squid game
season one he's everyone's favorite
gamboo player one o il nam but behind
that old seemingly innocent facade is
what many have argued is a criminal
mastermind but i'm here to tell you
don't believe those lies player one did
nothing wrong in this video i'll be
laying out the case for why illness bad
rap is unwarranted and how his decisions
throughout the game even ones that lead
to murder are actually benevolent but
before we begin make sure to like and
subscribe and if you need a refresher on
the show check out my squid game ending
explained i should first mention that my
argument here isn't that illnom is
perfect far from it every human is
flawed and this is represented
throughout our colorful cast of
characters songwoo is arguably the worst
of the lot lying about knowing one of
the games in advance tricking ali with a
fake bag of rocks resulting in his death
and the icing on the cake throwing
someone off the glass bridge hell even
gyun exploits ilnam's quote-unquote
dementia to avoid defeat in the marvel
game what i'm getting at here is that
ilnam is far from the most evil
character on the show in fact he shows a
lot of remorse and compassion but more
on that in a bit as we find out in the
series final episode player 1 is the
founder of squid game a game in which
contestants battle for their lives for
prize money and here is the first reason
oil nom did nothing wrong the games are
voluntary unlike similar death style
games like battle royale alice in
borderland or even the hunger games
contestants are given the opportunity
not to play we see this with guillen
who's given a card to enter he doesn't
have to go he does it on his own free
will even when he gets to the games he
signs a waiver which is juxtaposed to
the one he signed under duress from a
thug he owed money to in episode 1. gyan
and the other contestants did everything
voluntarily also address the argument
they didn't know they might die in the
first game later on in the video and if
this wasn't enough there's rule number
three contestants can choose to end the
games if the majority of players agree
illnam actually becomes the deciding
vote in ending the game if he was some
bloodthirsty maniac he would never have
voted to end it that's because ilnam has
an unspoken moral code about how the
game should be run who should be able to
compete and when it comes to him as a
player minimally affecting the outcome
the game's contestants aren't chosen at
random illness actually wants those who
need the money to participate in fact
there is a screening process of sorts
done through men like this guy who we
see engage geon in a game of dakji this
ensures contestants who take part really
need that money and the prize money
along with how it is distributed is
equally noble as we learn in episode 2
the total prize pool is 45.6 billion won
or roughly 38 and a half million us
dollars that's more than enough to
change someone's life and no matter the
outcome of the game money will be given
out if for example the contestants
decide to end the game the families of
the deceased will be given a hundred
million won illnom doesn't have to do
that but he does even though these
contestants voluntarily chose to be here
players are even given the chance to
come back to the games knowing it could
result in their deaths episode 2 is
titled hell and shows us the backstory
of several of these characters for them
life in the outside world is more of a
hell than playing the actual game ilnam
is merely giving them an opportunity
under their own volition to change the
course of their lives in a world which
has been so unfair to them but what sets
ilnam apart is that he actually plays
the game he puts his own life at risk in
order to play now i've seen a few
articles about how illnom supposedly had
the doll in the red light green light
game programmed so that it wouldn't kill
him i don't believe this for a few
reasons i went back and watched the
scene multiple times and you can clearly
see that illness does get scanned and
there are no indications that he moves
while on red light which would have
resulted in his death but i think the
point at which illness could have easily
died was the tug of war game his team
was clearly outmatched in strength and
even with his technique they used to win
the game they barely win if illness was
rigging these games to win this was
definitely not the play but for ilnam
it's not about winning he actually exits
the game after faking his death in
episode 6. in episode three illness even
thanks guyan for showing him the licking
technique in the honeycomb challenge
plus illness could have chosen the easy
triangle shape but went with the star
this is a guy who isn't afraid of a
challenge but perhaps the strongest
evidence that he didn't rig the red
light greenlight game is that it would
take the fun out of it on his deathbed
illness talks about the reason for both
starting the games and participating in
them fun as an extremely rich man
illness felt that nothing in life was
fun anymore there was no challenge no
fight nothing if he wanted something he
could easily buy it he has this great
line where he says the one thing that
extremely poor and extremely rich people
have in common is that for both of them
life is not fun if ilnam rigged the
games it would take away that fun
there's no fun in winning a game you
know you're going to win also if there
was no chance of death for him illness
would have risked exposing himself to
the other players there are also
multiple times in the show where the
front man espouses the virtues of having
fair and equal games so when it's
discovered that one of the contestants
has been given secret information about
the upcoming game that player is
eliminated during episode 4 it is ilnam
who stops the riot from killing everyone
in the dormitory while this massacre is
going on these soldiers merely wait for
instructions letting the killing
continue but it's only when illness
screams out for the killing to stop that
frontman sends in the army i personally
think this is because illness believes
this is not what the games are about we
can see him visibly upset in the
aftermath he even agrees to keep
nightwatch for his team in the aftermath
should another attack happen ilnam also
forges a relationship with gyan
something he probably shouldn't have
done if he generally wanted to see these
players killed in episode two when
they're in the outside world illnom
happens to show up where gian is and
even shares a pack of noodles with him
what a sweetheart and two episodes later
ilnam shows compassion while gion
recounts the story of his friend at the
car plant being murdered by police what
i'm getting at here is that ilnam isn't
the soulless character that a show like
this could have easily portrayed him as
there is humanity to him and this is
shaped by a moral code that acts as the
backbone to the games but the connection
between these two players really shines
in episode 6 gambu a korean slang word
roughly meaning friendship ilnam ends up
giving his player jacket to gyun after
gyun gave his own to cover up his pants
he lets geon win the marble game even
though gyun tried to exploit his
dementia in essence ilnom forgives him
here a forgiveness and compassion given
to gion based on the kindness he showed
him throughout the series and for quote
giving him a good experience the last
episode however is where we get the most
insight into who ilnam really is this
provides the backstory for why he
created the games and additional insight
into his worldview illnon believes we
make our own choices just like the drunk
man outside who chose to drink and
nearly kills himself in the cold he so
believes that humanity is not good that
he bets gion his life that no one will
help the drunk man and this in my
opinion is his biggest flaw he simply
has a misguided view of humanity it's
partially why he doesn't feel any guilt
for the thousands of contestants killed
over the years they chose to be there
they chose money over life so who is
really to blame in this twisted game the
man who created it or the contestants
who willfully choose to play it should
the drunk man blame the alcohol or
himself for choosing to drink it you can
see how it gets a bit more complex here
there's also this beautiful irony
between ilnam and the drunk man a man
who is literally sitting and dying
juxtaposed with what ilnam says in
episode 2.
now the main argument of this video is
that ilnam did nothing wrong and you
could say that he is the one responsible
for all these deaths but at the end of
the day the contestants voluntarily
chose to take that risk and you might
say well they didn't know they'd die in
the first round but they were expressly
told that if they follow the rules they
would not be harmed so those who didn't
follow the rules i.e moved during the
red light game were killed and any
liability toward illness would be
negated because of the player consent
forms a consent form which clearly
states in rule 2 that players who refuse
to play will be eliminated any of the
contestants could have specifically
asked what eliminated meant but none of
them do the real gray areas here that
i'm sure i'm gonna hear about in the
comments will likely fall on our own
subjective opinions on what is right and
wrong and that's the fun of these types
of videos one man's right is the other
man's wrong but i want to hear what you
think am i totally off here and illnom
is evil incarnate or is there a
different way of looking at things
remember all of you are my gambu and
please be kind to each other in the
comments thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much